[Musique]
une famille de pêcheurs en plein désert
devant les ruines de leur camp
aujourd'hui abandonné vestiges d'un
passé proche où ils attraper les
poissons à foison où il gardait quelques
bêtes et où il puisait l'eau douce
[Musique]
francisco se désole l'ancien fleuve ne
charrie plus que du sable un désert
s'est allongée dans son lit le colorado
est mort ici
sargos rejets d'eau on rangeait nos
barques cela ils en fassent aussi
empêché des muses des sardines des
cartes des poissons chats des grosses
crevettes elle allait d'une montagne à
l'autre c'était comme une mère quand
elle est partie
tout s'est asséché le poisson n'a plus
assez d'oxygène alors il a commencé à
mourir doulon là il s'est formé comme un
grand monticule de poissons nord l'eau
que l'on devine au loin est une
hallucination dû à la chaleur
un mirage rappel douloureux du temps où
le fleuve rencontre et ici l'océan et
formaient un estuaire immense
elle mayor le village principal des
pêcheurs du delta du colorado un fleuve
qui se jetait au mexique
c'était avant aujourd'hui le colorado
n'atteint presque plus la mer les
pêcheurs se retrouvent planté dans ce
nouveau désert une cinquantaine de
familles des indiens vivent ici les
coûts cas pas leur nom signifie les
pêcheurs de la rivière
autrefois des milliers ils ne sont plus
que 300 aujourd'hui éparpillés dans le
delta
comme le fleuve colorado le peuple de
francisco se meurt
tout était en train de se terminer
si l'on s'arrête notre vie est finie
parce que nous vivons de la pêche nous
mangeons les poissons ça a toujours été
comme ça du plus loin que je me
souvienne les gens ici étaient des
pêcheurs et en voyant ce fleuve en train
de mourir en voyant qu'il n'y a plus de
poissons que tout est polluée évidemment
ça fait mal qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
je me sens très impuissant en voyant
tous disparaître
milan de l'histoire des coûts cap a
balayé par les vents aride ce delta l'un
des plus grands au monde et en 17 ans
accule marécageux sur près de 8000
kilomètres carrés il est aujourd'hui
réduit à 5 % de sa taille d'origine un
désastre en quelques décennies visible
par satellite
[Musique]
n
où
[Musique]
prenant conscience des dégâts
l'état mexicain a créé une réserve
marine en 93 rosé campagne en est le
directeur
il doit gérer une catastrophe écologique
[Musique]
dans les mains une grande quantité de
coquillages mort d'une espèce endémique
du delta du colorado
c'est difficile d'en trouver un spécimen
vivant quand l'eau douce arriver
jusqu'ici ont trouvé cette à lourdes en
abondance avec la rétention et le manque
de 12 dans le delta
la salinité a changé l'espace a presque
disparu
les quasiment éteinte comme ces
palourdes un tiers de la flore et de la
faune du delta sont endémiques
plusieurs espèces de poissons de
mammifères marins et d'oiseaux sont
aussi en danger d'extinction
personne n'a encore mesurer l'ampleur de
ce bouleversement de millions des
millions de polonais accumulée dans ses
grands cimetières de coquillages rempli
d'histoire l'histoire récente du fleuve
colorado temps ce qui est ici dans ce
cimetière de coquillages c'est
incroyable ce que le rpt est capable de
faire en si peu de temps
la main de l'homme responsable d'une
telle catastrophe
il faut aller la chercher 600 km au nord
le colorado le voici de l'autre côté de
la frontière aux états unis emprisonné
dans un réservoir de 45 milliards de
mètres cubes d'eau
[Musique]
pour endiguer le fleuve capricieux les
américains ont construit un barrage
gigantesque l'eau couvre dame de 120
mètres de haut trois cent soixante dix
de large
il forma lac immense de 150 km de long
une oasis au beau milieu du désert le
plus aride des états unis
c'est en pleine grande dépression que le
pauvre dame est édifié
rail
merde
[Musique]
quatre ans de travaux plusieurs
centaines d'ouvriers un défi
technologique à l'époque le barrage est
érigée en symbole de la réussite
américaine
il est inauguré en 1935 par franklin
roosevelt
[Musique]
fini les inondations catastrophiques
pour la première fois les hommes
maîtrisent le fleuve
[Musique]
le pauvre dame est loin d'être le seul
ouvrage à enfermer le colorado d'autres
barrages ont suivi le long des sept
états américains traverser au début du
20e siècle
un accord entre les etats-unis et le
mexique établi un partage des eaux
inégale seuls 9% du colorado arrive
jusqu'au delta
[Musique]
s'affranchir du désert péché
coûte que coûte maintenant
[Musique]
non
privé de fleuve par les américains les
coûts capa en sont réduits à traverser
les grandes étendues ça l'est du delta
pour aller chercher la mère à une heure
de route de leur village
[Musique]
bateau file et équipements rien n'est
prévu pour affronter cette merde
bon
pas
[Musique]
les coûts capa doivent désormais jouer
avec les marées sans bien connaître ses
aléas
[Musique]
quand on rentre avec le poisson se
retrouve dans le virage là bas où c'est
complètement asséché à marée basse on
est empêtré dans la boue on n'arrive pas
à revenir on doit attendre l'eau pendant
des heures on attend la marée montante
pour rentrer
nous nous y sommes
son
ma
nokia
/
hachey salon
venise reconstitué en plein désert voici
las vegas ces casinos sa démesure
le venetian et l'hôtel le plus grand de
la planète avec plus de 7000 chambres
[Musique]
première ville hôtelière au monde la
cité de tous les péchés comme on la
surnomme est visité par 40 millions de
touristes par an
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une opulence duo pauvre dame le barrage
sur le colorado à quelques kilomètres de
là a permis l'essor de la ville en plein
désert petite bourgade il ya 50 ans deux
millions d'habitants aujourd'hui
un déluge de richesse une consommation
d'eau effréné près de 1000 litres par
jour et par habitant deux fois plus que
la moyenne américaine quatre fois plus
qu'en france
[Musique]
las vegas boit goulûment l'eau du
colorado
c'est cette femme qui gère
l'approvisionnement en eau de las vegas
un travail capitales pat malloy est l'un
des personnages les plus puissants du
nevada pressenti pour être le prochain
gouverneur de l'état
elle le sait mieux que quiconque sans le
colorado las vegas n'existerait pas
las vegas et la cité la plus sèche des
états unis elle est située en plein
désert du grave il ne pleut ici que 10
cm d'eau par an en seulement deux jours
toute la croissance de las vegas vient
du colorado 90 % de nos besoins sont
couverts par le fleuve
ce qui au milieu du changement
climatique et du réchauffement de la
planète et de notre propre impact sur le
colorado est assez terrifiant las vegas
le comprends tout juste elle doit
économiser le précieux liquide
après huit années de sécheresse la ville
commence à manquer d'eau d'ici cinq ans
elle n'en aura plus la cité a mis sur
pied une politique unique au monde 7
jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24
quinze officiers spécialisés patrouille
dans la ville
la mission de cette police de l'eau dans
cette vie d'abondance est un peu
surréaliste traquer les fuites
et bien une fuite
je donne juste un avertissement mais ce
n'est pas une amende ils ont 48 heures
pour réparer la fuite à ces deux jours
revient on regarde si c'était ou pas si
la fuite et réparer mon flow le dossier
non on met une amende
l'arrosage n'est autorisé que trois
jours par semaine un facteur 76 39
aujourd'hui on est le 10 avril les six
heures du soir sans train d'arroser 1
jeudi
c'est interdit l'amande va de 20 à 5000
$ en cas de récidive
à
[Musique]
l'écomusée de las vegas et c'est aussi
de sensibiliser les habitants aux
problèmes de l'eau des enjeux expliqué
par jeu vidéo
la pédagogie façon vegas
les politiques d'économie certes
efficace mais des rustines qui ne
changeront rien à la vie des indiens
cook a pas au mexique
car pour pat malloy la tsar de l'eau
comme on l'appelle pas question de
freiner le développement de sa ville la
croissance va continuer les grandes
métropoles n'ont jamais réussi à
contenir leur croissance les gens vont
là où il ya du travail
notre boulot c'est de procurer l'eau
nécessaire à notre communauté pour
qu'elle puisse survivre
las vegas veut bien réparer ces fuites
mais pas soigner sa boulimie
elle continuera sur consommer l'eau du
fleuve
peuple du colorado disparu les cook a
pas non plus le choix
dépossédés de leurs rivières ils doivent
s'aventurer en mer dans les bras du
delta deux fois par mois au printemps
ils partent attraper la courbe in une
espèce de barde une pêche longue
fatigante surtout très éloigné du
village les femmes elles ne viennent
plus jusqu'ici c'est trop loin
beaucoup ont des enfants en bas âge
elles doivent s'en occuper
quand on était près de nos elle n'avait
qu'à aller jusqu'aux berges du fleuve
elle péchait il est entré chez elle
maintenant c'est plus difficile
les coûts capa ne sont pas seulement les
victimes des américains
on entend la quantité de poissons de
corinne à ce mal
ils émettent un son comme un ronflement
le produisent avec leur vessie leurs
nageoires
c'est leur façon de communiquer pour
l'accouplement procès le directeur de la
réserve a aussi pris la mer ce matin
cette zone où les coûts capa pêche
désormais la seule possible juste à
l'entrée du delta se trouve en plein
coeur du parc marin
elle leur est interdite pour protéger la
reproduction des poissons projet veut
dissuader les pêcheurs de lancer leurs
filets il lui suffit de s'approcher de
leur barque
il s'enfuit aussitôt ils partent parce
qu'ils savent qu'ils n'ont pas le droit
de pêcher ici ils ont peur du
procès-verbal l'amande ça va de 20 à 40
mille pesos 4000 $ ils peuvent perdre
leur fils est le moteur et même la
barque
en fait nos problèmes ont continué avec
la création de la réserve marine
cela fait 13 ans que nous sommes en
procès avec l'état et le parc
nous le savons c'est illégal mais c'est
la zone où se trouve le poisson c'est
l'un ou l'autre soit nous pêchons là bas
où il n'y a pas d'eau soit au large en
pleine mer et on n'est pas équipé pour
sortir aussi loin
procès a le devoir de protéger la courbe
ina il est aidé dans sa mission par
l'armée
des fusils d'assaut contre des filets
une ironie de l'histoire les coûts capa
pêcheurs millénaire du delta dépouillés
de leur fleuve par les américains
aujourd'hui traqué par l'état mexicain
comme de dangereux délinquants les armes
c'est pour assurer la sécurité physique
des agents de l'état il ya déjà eu des
cas où les pêcheurs se sont jetés sur
nous ils ont renversé notre embarcation
quand il voit les armes ils ne font rien
prendre cisco et les siens ont eu de la
chance aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas été
arrêtés
le retour est rapide et à brut
[Musique]
les coûts capa ont pu revenir au
campement avec leur tech
la coopérative a ramené quatre tonnes au
village il s'agit maintenant de vendre
le poisson un acheteur et déjà la
[Musique]
prendre cisco essaient de négocier
il n'a toujours pas été payés en
totalité de sa dernière marée l'acheteur
veut bien prendre ces nouveaux poissons
mais donner l'argent plus tard
[Musique]
les pêcheurs ne lui font pas confiance
tu nous as pas payer bonhomme il veut
pas nous payer
on veut une reconnaissance de dette les
pêcheurs qui le connaissent disent
qu'ils ne payent pas ils disent tous que
ce type ne paye pas une barque ça fait
vivre quatre ou cinq familles ça fait
dix ou quinze personnes c'est aussi
simple que ça
[Musique]
on demande juste payer pour notre
travail comme les coûts cas pas à pêche
dans une zone interdite
ils n'ont pas de permis conséquence
personne n'a le droit d'acheter leurs
poissons seule solution le marché noir
la confiance prouvez nous on peut vous
faire confiance
les indiens se retrouvent à la merci
d'intermédiaires véreux
après deux heures de pourparlers
l'acheteur accepte la reconnaissance de
dette de tous signé un accord d'une
valeur juridique bien improbable
l'intermédiaire repart avec son stock de
poissons sans avoir déboursé un centime
et sans avoir donné la preuve de son
identité
les coûts capa n'arrive plus à vivre de
la pêche
alors il travaille aussi pour le
gouvernement sur des chantiers proches
dans l'une des régions les plus chaudes
de la planète
suzanne a construit des routes sous 55
degrés
cannes le programme est en place depuis
dix ans environ et on est bien obligé
d'y aller on n'a rien d'autre
ces trois mois par un nom mais il fait
trop chaud on ne peut pas travailler
plus d'une heure ou deux trop dur
peuples autrefois riche les coûts capa
sont aujourd'hui les laissés-pour-compte
d'un développement qui les ignore et qui
les exclut chaque jour de plus en plus
déclaré en danger par l'unesco
les pêcheurs cook a pas orphelins de
leur fleuve luttent pour leur survie
une survie qui dépend pourtant d'un
geste simple fraternelle un partage de
l'eau plus juste entre les hommes
quand tu regardes d'un côté aux états
unis c'est un océan d'eau les de ce côté
ci c'est tout c'est qu' il n'y a que de
la tête 6e ne lâche pas l'eau nous n'en
aurons pas où pouvons-nous trouver l'eau
douce c'est quelque chose que la plupart
des américains n'imagine même pas je
crois qu'il serait bon qu'il se rende
compte de notre situation
pour l'avenir je cherche mais non je ne
m'imagine pas s'empêcher
tu es triste oui assez
les larmes de francisco sont sèches
comme son fleuve
le colorado le combat d'un peuple oublié
[Musique]